Dans ce chapitre, on va explorer
comment les ordinateurs quantiques et classiques
travaillent ensemble pour résoudre l'un des défis les plus importants
en sciences : estimer avec précision l'énergie de molécules et de matériaux
On peut y parvenir
en utilisant un quantum circuit
pour générer des échantillons de base
qu'on va ensuite post-traiter
et diagonaliser grâce à un certain nombre d'algorithmes
dans cette famille de routines
comme SQV et SKG, et il existe un cours complet sur
la plateforme IBM Quantum consacré
à ces méthodes et aux méthodes associées
Pour nos besoins ici, on va
faire une explication brève
Que tu utilises SQV ou SKG,
ton objectif est de trouver les vecteurs propres
et les valeurs propres d'une matrice hamiltonienne
Cette matrice peut décrire l'énergie d'un système physique
ou chimique, mais le même cadre
peut traiter bien d'autres types de problèmes
comme la logistique, par exemple
Ces matrices peuvent être énormes,
donc réduire les dimensions
de la matrice tout en préservant les caractéristiques importantes
de l'état fondamental
peut avoir une grande valeur — c'est l'objectif de SQV
On utilise l'ordinateur quantique pour générer un sous-espace utile
qui contient l'état fondamental
On peut ensuite projeter notre matrice hamiltonienne
sur ce sous-espace, ce qui nous laisse
avec une petite matrice qui sera
beaucoup plus facile à diagonaliser
grâce au calcul classique haute performance — voilà comment on procède
en préparant un état quantique d'essai
souvent appelé un ansatz
et en effectuant des mesures pour échantillonner cet ansatz
dans la base computationnelle, ce qui nous donne
un sous-espace échantillonné dans la base computationnelle
mais ce qu'on veut vraiment trouver,
c'est le vrai état fondamental
Et si notre sous-espace échantillonné ne contenait pas
toutes les composantes nécessaires ?
Si on choisit un meilleur ansatz,
on pourrait obtenir une meilleure estimation de l'état fondamental
Ce qui nous amène à l'approche basée sur des échantillons :
le Krylov quantique basé sur des échantillons, ou SKUDY Dans SKUDY,
on commence avec un ansatz
comme avant, mais on applique ensuite des quantum gates qui approximent
l'évolution temporelle d'un système physique
On peut montrer qu'avec quelques hypothèses,
cela garantit un certain recouvrement entre l'évolution temporelle
de l'ansatz et le vrai état fondamental
Ces deux algorithmes partent d'énormes
matrices hamiltoniennes et fonctionnent un peu différemment,
mais dans les deux cas, la partie quantique de l'algorithme produit
un sous-espace qui nous permet de réduire notre matrice
en espérant préserver les caractéristiques clés de l'état fondamental
Alors, où intervient le calcul classique haute performance ?
Pour les plus grandes matrices hamiltoniennes
et pour les estimations les plus précises de l'état fondamental,
même ces matrices projetées peuvent être assez grandes
C'est pourquoi tirer parti de capacités de calcul classique plus puissantes
peut nous aider non seulement
à obtenir de meilleurs résultats,
mais aussi à nous permettre de s'attaquer à des problèmes plus grands
Pour tout mettre ensemble,
on peut représenter les algorithmes basés sur des échantillons
comme une combinaison de différents modèles de programmation
sur un ensemble de ressources hétérogènes
Par exemple, on peut représenter notre algorithme
comme un workflow de tâches où on aura une tâche
pour la préparation du quantum circuit avec un recouvrement
avec notre état cible, suivi d'une tâche
pour le transport, qui ne nécessite que des ressources classiques
à exécuter ensuite, il y aura la tâche
qui utilise des primitives pour exécuter notre quantum circuit
ce qui, évidemment,
sera suivie d'une tâche de post-traitement qui elle-même
peut être une diagonalisation parallèle avec un algorithme
tournant sur plusieurs nœuds
on peut aussi vouloir exécuter
l'un de ces algorithmes plusieurs fois
pendant qu'on fait varier nos paramètres
ou les lancer complètement en parallèle
avec différentes populations
maintenant, mettons tout ça ensemble avec SKUDY
en code aussi — voici tous nos fichiers de tâches
et voici tous nos fichiers de soumission
dans la tâche de mapping, on prépare les circuits.
Dans l'étape d'optimisation, on fait tourner les circuits de la meilleure façon.
Dans la tâche d'exécution, on échantillonne simplement les bitstrings
à partir de l'état préparé par
notre ISA circuit.
qu'on obtient de l'étape précédente
et on effectue notre post-traitement.
On est maintenant prêts à soumettre notre
workflow SKUDY.
Comme tu peux le voir, tout s'enchaîne en séquence
avec les dépendances — attendons
les résultats et on peut vérifier nos fichiers de sortie.
Voici le fichier de sortie de l'étape d'optimisation
où on a notre ISA circuit.
Et vérifions enfin notre fidélité
de génération.
Depuis le planning.
Et voilà pour la démonstration rapide du workflow SKUDY
tout le code sera disponible dans la section texte
ou dans la description ci-dessous
et voilà, on vient de parcourir quelques
concepts et exemples qui peuvent t'aider à démarrer avec
la gestion de programmes hybrides complexes — bien sûr,
si tu apprécies ça, on n'a fait qu'effleurer la surface de
tout ce que tu peux faire avec la combinaison du quantique
et de ressources classiques spécialisées — pour en savoir plus,
consulte la documentation et les tutoriels
sur la plateforme IBM Quantum
et n'oublie pas de consulter les ressources partagées dans la section texte
ou la description pour plus d'éléments
et de logiciels — merci d'avoir regardé.
Ouais.